one day my friend told me let's have a  cigarette he handed me a bottle of  pineapple juice and said this would  really [ __ ] you up it didn't feel like  anything and so I went to first period  when I got to first period I started  seeing blurred vision and I had stomach  pains  felt like somebody was grabbing a  machete and stabbing me in the stomach  repeatedly  all I remember was just turning back and  looking at one of my classmates and I  was just like I'm I'm in trouble I can't  see anything I'm I'm blind I'm going  blind  that class ends and I was walking with  like a totally blind person my arms out  I thought it was just something that it  would come and go and I blacked out  turns out that pineapple juice had  rubbing alcohol now this next part might  sound insane the doctors called my mom  and my father to let them know that I  wasn't gonna make it I died